[Music]
before we start do you have insurance
what your coverage good like you have
dental oh haha is there a hospital
nearby is it like too far it's about
like 25 minutes I'd
say I just slapped you are you all right
what so you like to fight you ever win
no one ever wins a fight
[Music]
[Applause]
this ain't the holiday and pal all right
I'm
moving friend of mine suggested I come
talk to you I own a roadh house out in
the Florida
Keys lately it's been attracting the
wrong
clientele I can pay you good money
judgeing by your car you need that well
I like my car think about it come
on
know who you are Elwood dton
B that guy's got a knife under his shirt
you just take a big step back and pop me
in the face you can do
it tell me about this bouncy yeah it's
all nice like he's Mr Rogers or
something but then he'll haul
off really interesting guy
overall gr wants to take the Roadhouse
away from me he wants to build some
Resort I should warn you people have a
certain way of getting things done
around
here hey fellas looks like you're having
a smacky ni
do I got a tip for you don't let no one
get this close come
on let me guess no threaten me tell me
to get out of
town I get the impression that you can't
be
threatened
once KN is on the job it's over
baby it takes a lot to get me angry but
when I
am I just can't let
go people seem a little aggressive
around
[Music]
here is that one a front of yours no I
just broke his
arm
close your
eyes and you will find
[Music]
yourself when I was a
boy my mother used to tell me a
story of a demon king and his
army they brought fire and Terror to the
land
until they face the protector of the
people the white
monkey there you
are you are a
beast in this city the rich don't see us
as
people give me the job no one wants to
do I'll do it
anyone who forgets their pleas it
doesn't turn out well for
[Music]
them this is not the place to work if
you can't handle that sort of
stuff every
day I've prayed for a way to protect the
weak I've got an answer to every prayer
I call on
Nikki Minaj big bumper nice head like
life let's boo
[Music]
it we got over
MC 1 2 1 2
[Music]
3 need to fight for your mother for all
of
us anger will not Qui to your soul my
son don't call me
[Music]
son it's time to
remember but only love war will they
learn
anal just one small
Ember can burn down
everything ladies and
gentlemen are you ready for the [__]
fight 1 2
[Music]
here hello everybody what's up where the
minut three girls one wife something is
missing this guy oh there's my
boy I know you love your D go up say
it yes of course he loves you he just he
just doesn't show it on his face or with
his body language right crew Junior come
on grw I need a word with you your
family's lives are at stake
what Max laal has escaped from prison
I'm coming for my room avenge
group we have to get to the safe house
it has aeng machine I love this
place the most important part of a heist
is being aware of potential
dangers I tranked
myself
[Music]
no
what
intrud
thanks
Ron fire in
the
I've been waiting 40 years for this they
called themselves Ghostbusters according
to these hacks they saved the world no
eyewitnesses and who is found to carry
the torch descendence of Egon Spangler
you have a minor hanging out the side of
a moving vehicle firing a laser gun
indiscriminately has a proton P it's
completely safe I wouldn't say
completely safe the Ghostbusters are
finished right well overruled
sustained thank
you you the weird guy who buy strange
all things correct on both counts buddy
you just hit the
jackpot what is it better question is
what's inside of
it The Parables fell of an unimaginable
evil commanding an Army of
Ghosts that's the power to kill by fear
itself like literally scared to
[Music]
death we might be looking at our second
Ice
Age we're going to need all the help we
can get let's get to
work can I be of any help melet in
uniform
yes is there something
strange but there's something weird who
are people going to call Ghostbusters
what do you
[Music]
want where are the Ghostbusters can I
tell you something else what bust it
makes me feel good makes me feel
good heads up all dark and horny at
12:00
[Music]
yeah the Nikki what up man are you
serious I have someone call me when you
get out of surgery all right you should
drive out there Ricky's been there for
you guys your whole life
the devil's in the details my friend it
work Atlantic City here we come what we
got Ricky's cancer's back why does it
have to be cancer won't everybody get
worried yeah and that's going to take us
right into the World
[Music]
Series Ricky Nikki the best friend we
never
had my baby's going to be born 6 weeks
early I was born 6 weeks
early I want to know where the hell you
guys were tonight we called every
hospital and there was no record of a
Ricky St Nikki you know all we did was
tell one lie hundreds and hundreds of
times over many many years if the truth
does come out my marriage is over what
if we hire an actor to play
sikki Rock Hard Rod x-rated rock and
roll impersonator I do a whole act wall
the wall top to bottom JZ jams thanks
for coming out tonight ladies and
gentlemen so horny to be here this is a
really bad
idea oh Jesus I've been cold turkey in
the booze Ricky Snick in the program
remember oh Rod it's not what you think
it is it's just I'm a hyper every time I
want you to admit that Ricky St Nikki
does not exist
[Applause]
hey this is Ted summer Hayes my boss Ted
nice to meet you dig in the suit in the
seedlings man the seedlings the hair
plugs they're new right this is my hair
we're going to lose our
[Music]
job epic night am I right guys throw it
out and come back in that's my best
friend I was really taken with your
friend sikki he's got brass balls on him
that guy that's why I hired him that's
awesome you just said what did you say
just say it one more time we can't out
of our sight not only did I miss the
birth of my son but I let some pornno
Peter Frampton impersonator snip his and
we're done Nikki you are unbelievable
show's over rod it's Ricky Ricky siki is
it real my job sucked I had no friends
but now I have all those
things are you a fraud sir what you
talking
about my best we got to get rid of
him every time he tries to make a point
it's like he's smoking invisible dogs
dear God it's true to support now it
looks like I'm cupping the
[Music]
balls Gus March
Phillips I have a mission I want you to
lead thank you Sergeant what's the plan
to neutralize the German huberts in the
North Atlantic
we're losing the
war Hitler is not playing by the rules
so neither are
we we both know that I'm not very
popular with the administration the
reason they find you unattractive is the
very reason I find you a
attractive if time to do this I'll need
my own
team you won't like them let go
all bad they'll need to
[Applause]
[Music]
be this is an unsanctioned unauthorized
Mission if we fail England will be
condemned to a lifetime under the German
[Music]
Boot and so I said that is not a dog
that is my
wife ha it's very
[Music]
good you and your operation are
Reckless abort this Mission
now hello can't hear you please do off
[Music]
huh my name is Sharon I'm just a ticked
off hairdresser with a split and
headache I'm good at plenty of things
taking no prent answer ain't one
them you just wandered into a lady you
never met before his funeral why exactly
something about that little girl just
five and she already needs a liver
transplant
hi Sharon remember me yes ma' so she's
going to help out a few nights a week I
met this woman she's a mess perfect
she'll fit right
in I'm going to put together a press kit
for Michelle get corporate donations
that kind of thing we don't need to be
running around worried about money and
bills right now I just want to be with
my family L about saying yes and then
figuring out how girls help your daddy
out
I'm not comfortable with this I'm her
father I'm supposed to be the one taking
care of her you're going to have to get
comfortable being uncomfortable cuz this
ain't about you it's about your little
[Music]
girl Michelle will need to fly to the
Children's Hospital immediately I've had
patients who have missed that window
because they couldn't get a flight don't
lose your faith over
this officials are saying be prepared
for what they're calling the worst
blizzard in State
history
is
it
today okay we'll be
there you want to go on an adventure I
let you
go the roads haven't been ploud that the
airport's closed honey listen it's it's
too dangerous I have to make it this is
our last chance if we don't take it
Michelle
[Music]
dies someone's got to do something
someone's got to fight for
but one thing I know for sure that
little girl now has the entire city
rooting for
[Music]
her I want you to know something you're
not just worthy Sharon you're a
[Music]
miracle you want to be a normal teenager
I got news for you you're not normal
Doris who's
Doris uh I
am do you think this is the right place
for him you say that about any place my
brother's dying he hasn't talked in
years I'm so sorry my wife passed away
my dad died when I was three Christ it
ain't
competition I think I should start
sleeping at Sunco so your brother
doesn't get too lonely he's my child
when he's in pain I'm in pain I'm your
child too what about God sake give me a
break you can come to my house if you
need to place a party my mom won't be
there and you can do whatever you want I
I I have to tell everybody um but who
who are
you everyone says this neighborhood is
scary but like when you're in it it's
like not that
scary thank
you it's really hard taking care of sick
people sometimes you need a
break I dare need to kiss
D he could have died and you weren't
here once your brother's gone he's
gone and you will miss taken care of him
you'll miss everything all the good all
the
bad we're going to have fun again you
and
me I'll learn how to be fun
again Doris old lady's name was my
grandma's name oh she died the day I was
born my God is there any conversation
with you that is not like thoroughly
depressing to
[Music]
me welcome to my
world for most of human
civilization we believed that life could
only
exist on the surface of our planet
what else were we wrong
[Applause]
about this world has more
secrets
are you hot for
any Lisa does he have more of a
basketball b or a football B he doesn't
play sports
my Tender Is grave I talk to him I wish
I was been
you that's really weird
[Music]
Lisa you hear that I'm sure it's the
girl next door she's very
odd your
hand can't believe you're here do you
like music I have to cure oh not that
kind of cure they can't make you better
I mean they can but like emotionally
okay no don't cry your tears smell so
bad send it back you need a friend no I
love it it's not really my
style when you're inou LSA looks good
she could probably even do pageants if
she had
Congeniality your daughter is a little
psycho I open my glorious home to an
ungrateful
little I want to help you but Taffy says
it's a waste of time to try and fix a
white he better just accept a guy father
oh that's so
cute I have an idea there are bad people
out there come on Lisa it'll feel
good that hand is going to do terrible
things you are being admitted impatient
lock
down I could get the clink for light or
the electric chair but I don't want to
die a
virgin you know anything about The
Disappearance of a
student I'm not making any more comments
you can talk to my lawyer really hope
this goth phas in soon you need a
friend ready come work for Uncle Sam
Secret Service
Daddy get some sleep okay I need your
fresh tomorrow what happens tomorrow one
of my agents called in sick you're on
Air Force One
D I break this one in yes
sir it's all yours General it's the
president sit back and enjoy the
rides let's the off first we have to
take the pl back remember kid you only
have one job protect the
president Air Force One this is Andrew's
Air Force based air traffic control
please acknowledge over
Air Force One come
in oh my
God we're still Gathering Intel we're
coordinating the search for survivors
for bodies not in my
pres
hi you FL the skin of Agent M mil 1 in
at a
time now tell
me do you think I'm
[Music]
lying yourself what's
happened
sooner or later he will make a mistake
and it'll be the last mistake he ever
makes I don't write songs to be
famous I write songs
cuz I don't know what I do if I
didn't in my head
hello my
tears get without
[Applause]
my I want people to hear my
voice and just forget their
troubles you got remember I ain't no spy
scale me war
house we only stle by
we
I I want to be
remembered for just being
[Music]
me to lose one's
family home
[Music]
everything what would I do if that
happened to
[Music]
me
I know what they say about
me about hopeless
Romantics that we're
weak and I'm not
weak that learned the hard
way
not all love stories have a happy
ending turns up let's pick this back up
next week I just want to what are you
guys doing here we think you might be a
sex addict every time I see you what
maybe I'm still
in there times a charm this guy don't
stand a chance this is me
haven't been sleeping well
lately I guess I never have this me when
I was little I used to share a room with
my
sister she used to sleep so peacefully
this is me and I just used to lie there
awake
[Music]
thinking how does anybody sleep that way
when your heart never goes to
sleep I know you feel like nobody gets
you I don't even get me this is
It's never enough for you he's a liar
I've never lied to you the constant
criticism she thinks I'm her
employee being with you feels like
home but I left home for a
reason whenever someone asked me what I
wanted to be when I grew
up my answer was
always in
love
you must respect the Ed and flow of the
universe this is
me is
[Music]
me on three big breath in
one
[Music]
Waverly hi Auntie what are you doing
here I haven't had time off since med
school so now is my chance before I
started my
residency I haven't told my
[Music]
parents you made it hi you're Rachel's
neighbor I'm I'm Blake nice to meet
[Music]
you she
okay
are you okay I'm okay are you okay
me morning hi you can't swim huh I kind
of missed that as a kid I could teach
you why are you doing this like spending
time with
you tell me about your parents I've been
doing them 4 years they make sure I have
everything that I need but they don't
really know
me are you looking at me no
I kind of have feelings for Blake no
kidding here you are having the best
summer of your life going after a boy
you like I think I see love birds she's
thinking about moving here it's too soon
right hi Mom Dr Wong squeeze you into
his research team this is for your
future my parents want me in Toronto I'm
not normally very
impulsive well can we just stay in the
moment want
to
[Music]
CH Bly you lied to us I want to stay
here with you but I do want to be a
doctor I don't have to act like this is
anything more than
summerling it's time you ask yourself
what you want to do I don't want this
Sumer to end you have to make yourself
known in this life not for anyone
else but for
you
[Music]
I just don't think you understand how
Tinder Works can I tell you something I
know exactly how Tinder works then you
don't understand how flirting
Works how do you think you got
[Music]
here it hurts where
honey everywhere
[Music]
unique you made my head silent who are
you talking to can you please just come
out so she can see
you madam you need to save it by to your
order you have to get strong now I can't
you can and you have to let me help you
life every life
ends I felt the pain that you have
I don't know uh what I am without you
who I am without
you I don't know what the world is
without you in
it I love you more
than anything in the whole
world you'll be okay
promise
promise promise promise
[Music]
promise the echo you leave the Legacy
your memory is how she
lives in the name of the father and of
the Son and the Holy Spirit and
hello I know God saved me for a reason
but guess I'm still searching for what
that reason
is too much brother of
[Music]
Christ it's a
miracle you are with
[Music]
child out of all the women in the
world why did he troose me how can we
trust what's inside
[Music]
you
suffering you should
Lov
suffering
suffering yes
loves
[Music]
what was your plan back
there it's like a 14-hour drive to get
to Santa Fe didn't think that far ahead
to be honest dad you're pretty out of
shape
[Music]
though are you
hungry a sweet tooth you got from me
oh is that all I got from
you somebody order a
stripper can I get you anything I'll
take a
[Music]
beer oh hey oh okay let's go no we're
just having a conversation excuse me 12
hours ago 12 hours ago you
OD
trust me this path you're on is not
worth it what do you care you're an
addict guess who I learned that
from
window I've been there and um my life
started to slip away I just couldn't
stop I didn't really know what it meant
to be a
father but I would like to get to know
you
why would I ever trust you you've never
been there for me
Dad I'm just trying to find my
[Music]
[Applause]
daughter live your
life there's something greater something
better come
on come on I
don't
in
P look at that this is actually a
depiction of a swan but what do you see
what do you feel I feel you don't live
here Ronnie she could stay here but I
can't get a dog she's my sister there's
a difference yeah there's a difference
you can have sex in front of a dog
today's a big day for Anna they're doing
one of those big
auctions if I want to work at a top Art
Gallery I got to get a good
recommendation and there is no better
recommendation than Claire
Dupont good morning everyone Irwin's
clients are about to walk through that
door and I will not allow them to see
anything less than Perfection you what's
that massive oil spill on the back of
your shirt it's not like we work for a
sociopathic perfectionist or anything oh
God hello it's Claire your boss I need
an extra assistant I just got invited to
go to London with Claire
Dupont you're not on this flight I put
you on one that leaves in 4 hours an
economy you've just been upgraded first
class I'm William what brings you to
London our London branch has called in
the director of the New York office wow
you seem a bit young to be the director
yeah the youngest director in company
history if you're not too busy being up
to Swanky art director I would love to
take you out I lied to him about so many
things you are here for work not for
play I got you the reservation tickets
for this
evening going to invite me inside excuse
me what happened to your manners down T
ABI mom she's a director of an auction
house in New
York I would like you in charge of my
auction I'm going to do it I'm jealous
of your Hannah Montana
lifestyle Santos a word
please you're a New Yorker and being a
New Yorker means that you fight every
single
day Rocky bbo said that isn't he from
Philly he moved there from
[Music]
Brooklyn
after the night when I wake
up I see what
to
[Music]
you don't have to be
afraid this child is his
way are
you
wait wait wait hold on you okay yeah
great okay I'll be right back
get you see
[Music]
underwear Tom are you okay do I know you
man no but i't been watching over you
your whole life who are
[Music]
you
waa I know it's cool your grandmother
was a guardian sworn to protect
Humanity now the duty of protecting it
is yours very funny right it's time to
start your training oh it's
[Music]
on whoa okay hold on no no no no
no wait how did you know I was going to
survive I didn't is that a
dragon show off it will be my honor to
guide you wait we're getting di some not
everything is what it seems
[Music]
kid
zodiac sworn to protect the guardian
who's the featherweight hi I'm Tom
lactose intolerant and guardian of a
Steph Curry rookie card what feel the
power inside you oh
yeah
wait you don't talk too do you this
about to be
on we need you for what's
coming who said kids can't fly and I
hope you ain't afraid this I don't know
if I can be who you need me to be your
grandma believed in you it's in your
blood I've waited a thousand years for
this
moment I am the guardian we've got this
zodiac up oh yeah
you know that it's coming
yeah
know I'm Dr Filer and my goal is to heal
your mind and reintegrate you into
society as soon as possible I'm not EX
same they Cal
wait you're making a
mistake after 18 months today is the big
day 18 months are you okay Stephen I
saved you from years in
prison really don't remember thing baby
step no nothing doctor said one every
morning I'm fine something's not
right father please go
now I just got this awful
feeling It's All Coming Back not the
person that I thought I was I want to
know exactly what's going on you're
mistaking dreams for
memories these aren't
dreams don't makeing any
sense I feel like I'm
C I'm here but I'm not
here it's a sick experiment the doctor
say this might happen
I'm not going to hurt you Steven maybe
it's time we call a doctor how long
we've been friends how long we've been
friends I honestly can't even remember
well that's
right I'm innocent my mind is never
yours you remember what we want you to
remember I know what they're doing here
I
got close your eyes and relax we'll get
[Music]
started you all came highly
recommended you know the rules no real
names no backstory
[Music]
no cellon so whose kid is she a very
wealthy man who's about to be $50
million
poorer I'm here to make sure you're safe
what's your name mine's Abigail you can
call me Joey do you have any
kids I have a little boy see you in 24
hours do you know what a pinky promises
if you behave and do as we
say I pinky promise you it'll all be
over
soon Joey yeah I'm sorry about what's
going to happen to
you what the
[__] [__] we got to get out of
here I think she knows
something
guys
guys guys
oh
no what the [__] is that thing we
kidnapped a [__]
[Music]
vampire a ballerina
vampire okay how do we kill a vampire
what are we talking about like an an
rice or True Blood you know Twilight
steak through the heart daylight is a
big
one all right let's go kill us a [__]
vampire
ready
vampire on
[Music]
[Applause]
my look can I say I like playing with my
food whoa whoa whoa she's [__]
flying
[Music]
a I [__] hate
ballet The Mystery of the obscene little
Hampton letters is causing widespread
distress Across the
Nation AIS Swan takes it up the and she
loves it more than Christmas day only
words mother she sucks 10 a week minimum
holy Heavens in the end I think it's
just
jealousy Rose goody you are writing
these Wicked little letters to Edith's
SW why would I send a letter when I can
just say it I'll get you in the ball s
she's
heinous you want in the nose you old
beetle beetle
right you're charging her what's the
evidence let me on you w time
similarities in the language I've got a
daughter at home why would I risk it all
in prison Rose my find some Kindred
Spirits in prison no no not the murders
or the rapists I'm thinking more the
drunks and the queers maybe just trying
to find a bright
side I believe we may be charging an
innocent if you meddle in my case these
will be on your wrists makes me wonder I
think you've been set up Rose is there
anyone who want to do such a
thing we got a pen and
paper I like you Rose I ha
her you don't like the idea of me
leaving this house
dear you are a Serial liar no we'll find
who wrote these
letters oh god oh
Jesus I notic they say foxy ass a lot
nobody swears like that what would you
say you look like Queen Victoria
sh you
[Music]
da
this diary Diary of the man who captured
it Chronicles how he Enslaved the yakara
in this box forever you want me to go
and steal
Fox first
Raven I need you to find
[Music]
it
this is all because of
you I didn't mean for any of this what
is that thing
[Music]
[Applause]
Graven
everyone wondered how the world broke
we're under
attack deep down before Society
collapsed we were already falling over
the car it was only a matter of time
before it all
crumbled try to hold your breath hold
your breath I saw this so it be nuclear
are you
scared America's just been attacked get
to the homestead is this an ark or is
this a
fortress it would take a miracle for
this to work but I believe in
miracles everyone wants to know how the
world
ended this is the story of how it began
again 30 seconds to on
air okay and you are just here
good my said father
back now an extraordinary story about a
young man who many years ago visited
prag what he found there with thousands
of refugees at the mercy of Hitler's
imminent
Invasion do you ever think about the
children and what happened to
them bet you got some stories
that's really not about
me we are working to evacuate these
children by train to Safety in Britain
why are you doing this Mr Winton because
I may be able to do something about it I
must go
now Nikki you must know we cannot save
them all you have to forgive yourself
that I'm starting sir I have to finish
it we cannot let these people
down it is incredible what you
achieved we're doing as much as we
can you have a lot of faith in ordinary
people because I'm an ordinary
person save one life save the world but
forgive me but how many children are we
speaking about
can I ask is there anyone in the
audience tonight who owes their life to
Nicholas
[Music]
Winton did you ever see
aie did you ever see go way
and Theo when Theo was born I couldn't
even hold
him okay I was afraid I was going to
drop
him I'm a terrible mother you're a
wonderful
mother and a wonderful
friend I just want you to be happy
too Max Max get down it's not safe
Max did you ever see a last go this way
yep Max is
gone wasn't easy bringing you into this
world now you've left her too
soon
go you need to separate the grief from
the guilt what guil
Alice something's broken inside of me
and I need
you I saw the look in her eyes she
thinks that I should a Sav person is
that coming from her or you you think
I'm imagining
things we're not going down this path
again you're
right God knows I can get carried away
sometimes can Theo come over for a
little bit it's amazing how quickly you
forgot my son our
son it helps me to spend time with Theo
but it helps him too do you miss
him's my friend friend get off the
balcony P wrong did you did you put Theo
on that balcony to test me do you think
I'm capable of
that she wants us to pay for
mag you're just accusing me of being
some kind of monster you're losing touch
with reality leave my family
alone I'm not imagining
things
this is a story about me Leah and T how
is the shop doing well it
is it seems like you are making
something of yourself in my it's a
Chinese tradition to have your fortune T
before begin
[Music]
EV we can celebrate Le
successful I'm in
control
yes five days H Jesus has answered my
[Music]
prayers we each pick one date and I
already have the perfect man in mind I
have a $50 bet on my date Dad I'm not
some slot machine Leah don't say
[__] come you will be my public facing
wife wait
what what she needs is someone who is
loyal yeah you have to try it what did
you say this one again oh oh my
God
o oh my
gosh my God something died oh and they
were buried in your
mouth Richard it's good to see you mhm
oh this is a nightmare not meeting
anyone
new Grandma I know what you're going to
say suck it up and get back out
there dating is just a numbers game and
your number happens to be
five in 6 months we'll begin trying for
children three Sons
minimum my grandma told me to follow my
dreams you
feeling I'm the
failure even though I'm still prettier
it's all I
[Music]
have why is this the best date so far if
you want to do some over the pants stuff
we could oh good I was dreading
[Music]
yeah we got some fresh fish fell welcome
to my jail
son you're in here cuz they say you got
to pay I'm in here to make sure you do
congratulations Adams you are a father
nobody told you you're going to spend
the rest of your life in here you ain't
never going to see
that truth is I never thought about
being a
father he's your little Mama's Boy you
know you don't have to be like him right
but I just want to be there for my
[Music]
kid if Freedom's a state of mind I guess
my dream should be
enough just think about how much better
your kid's going to be without you
around
bco when you going to grow
up I ain't content with
dreaming humans are the greatest
weakness in any security system prisons
aren't
inescapable they just meant to feel that
way run the streets as we adap to Crime
trap my body if they trap my mind need
your help I know the game bro down 23
when you s even theind man see he in
Reading going to save your ass no I do
not sir I'm stry have at it I'm so close
to not only freedom but also to being a
real
father I would like to help you I go
there more than anything in the world
I'm
think I
[Music]
it I'm
think I make you can only protect
yourself by your choices
think I got to make
[Music]
it such a morbid
imagination bringing dead
things to
life hey she emerges from her cave hello
when do you think you finished this film
with yours I don't
know what's all that stuff it's called
stop motion animation what do you think
it's a bit boring it's not finished it's
not boring make a new one a new one yeah
I know better story you want to hear
hear
[Music]
it there's a
girl she's
scared there's someone
coming who's coming the man no one wants
to meet the
Ashman you can bring it to
life
what does the ash man do don't be
scared whatever it is you think you saw
back there it's not
real I don't want to make this film
anymore you want to hear the next bit of
the
story I want to go I want to
go what happens when it takes on a life
of its
[Music]
[Applause]
own 12 cards in the
circle one more at the
heart with this final
card your reading will start that's
terrifying yeah this old deck is kind of
strange where did you find
them an unspoken Ru not to use somebody
else's cards who cares who's going
first follow my rule to stay out of
danger
hello you're never to deal with the
death of the
[Music]
stranger
mag
death whose face will you
see when you take your last breath
[Music]
[Applause]
who's
next
are you
okay 32-year-old Beacon Hill resident
Megan roads had been assumed dead by the
police after she disappeared from a
nearby parking garage nearly 6 months
earlier
sorry my great-grandfather bought this
place in the 20s I
think it's pretty empty in the winter
good I'm really sorry about what
happened to you thank you is anyone else
coming down doubt
it Meg I'm sorry this is my cousin
meline we've got a big family I won't
hold it against you
after what you went through you'll never
feel normal again how are you guys
related her cousins there's just
something off about her what are you
nervous about is it all the talk of
death I think I saw your mother she
hasn't left that room in
months you remember what drct Potter
said sometimes nightmares can feel
really
real why did you bring me
here where were
you when I was
gone you're broken you can't tell what's
[Music]
real and C Bry green it don't matter how
old you are how much money you got how
big or tall or
small what do you call Three Trees what
a
trio you ever think about what it would
be like outside of here wow this is
where we from such a big rad out there
so much I want to do you're never too
little set your mind to it you can do it
I'm putting my mind to some McDonald's
right now and I don't see it on my
plate man and Eric we've done everything
together since we were
born you got dreams sometimes whoever
had a dream that felt so real you
thought you was
awake you know we always wanted better
that's why we came
here now how am I supposed to keep you
[Music]
safe what everything that's been going
on they're moving out Malik didn't tell
[Music]
you I'm just mad cuz I'm leaving not a
baby anymore you're grown now and you
know right from
Rome this is what I know a place is the
[Music]
people my name and my name ER don't you
forget
it hey oh
[Music]